be sure to check out my video title
Deadpool explained there you'll find a
more in-depth explanation of Deadpool
and his publication history so what I
wanted to do here is have a discussion
on the character of Deadpool and what
I'm hoping is that by the end of this
video you'll have an understanding of
why so many people love him and by
extension why he's one of Marvel's most
popular characters
so while the reason for Deadpool's
creation is well known by comic book
fans to have its roots in the character
Deathstroke and antagonist from DC's
lineup of Teen Titans stories the
original depiction of Deadpool as it was
created in 1991 by Rob Liefeld and Cavey
and Miss ISA was in fact Deathstroke
down to a tee
much like Deathstroke Deadpool was a
serious mercenary highly skilled in his
trade and was initially hired to kill
the mutant cable and new moons issue
number 98 now following his first
appearance in me-me-me's issue number 98
while Deadpool saw a share of features
alongside characters and teams and
Marvel comics including Wolverine
daredevil The Avengers and Heroes for
Hire the initial appearance of the
Deadpool character was a bit of a
refreshing introduction as a result
under Mark Waid in 1994 Deadpool was
given a miniseries titled sins of the
past a story which garnered a bit of
attention ultimately leading to Marvel
launching a solo series under fledgling
writer Joe Kelly in 1997 in my previous
video on Deadpool explained we discussed
the impact Joe Kelly had on the Deadpool
character where Rob Liefeld Deadpool was
serious and modeled to be identical to
DC's Deathstroke Joe Kelly instead chose
to take a more comedic approach and so
what I want to do here is I want to wind
the clock back and I want to have a
discussion about why this communication
of Deadpool was such a refresher from
the rest of Marvel's offerings as we
discussed in previous videos about
Marvel Comics leading up to the 1990s
the most popular of these titles were
the x-men by and large under Chris
Claremont the x-men found success with
stories like God loves man kills the
Dark Phoenix and Phoenix sagas among
others while these stories struck a deep
chord in readers in terms of how they
view the world of comics they're serious
tones combined with the constant
possibility of various members dying set
the stage for future Marvel stories
1981's Avengers annual number 10 The
Punisher vol 1 in John Byrne's 1982 1986
run of the Fantastic Four were perfect
examples of Marvel's recognition of
stories that could be created with
more dramatic and serious tones at the
time Marvel's only real source of comedy
came in the form of spider-man and his
Marvel's flagship characters
spider-man's popularity was used as a
way to break the monotony of darker
stories but even he saw a shift
following 1984 Secret Wars crossover
when his character dawn the now infamous
Venom symbiote in the form of a black
costume while the various stories
provided under these standards of drama
were compelling the stories themselves
also maintained the idea that these
characters were simply that characters
on a piece of paper written by writers
and drawn by artists while this had been
the standard of comic books and
virtually all literary works since their
inception Joe Kelly came along with the
Deadpool solo series and shattered this
glass wall providing readers with a
character that was not only funny in a
time of dark stories but set the
foundation for Deadpool interacting with
the reader as they read the story itself
while Deadpool breaking the fourth wall
is a mainstay for his character this was
not a recurring theme under Joe Kelly
while Deadpool did break the fourth wall
during Joe Kelly's run once under the
influence of hallucinogens and another
while sober initial focus was put on
Deadpool effectively being a parody of
superheroes themselves to this end Joe
Kelly wrote stories in a manner where
Deadpool himself was well aware of the
fact that he was in a comic book and by
extension would hope fun at the plot
points and ask the same questions that
readers would ask as to why the story
was happening but furthermore villains
and heroes like bullseye Thor Captain
America and others that were previously
depicted as serious or dangerous in the
respective publications were depicted in
silly or ridiculous ways in the Deadpool
stories now as much before under Joe
Kelly Deadpool broke the fourth wall
twice with his first occurrence taking
place in Deadpool volume 1 issue number
27 while in Japan disguised as an old
woman
Deadpool encounters wolf rain when
Wolverine is able to detect Deadpool by
his scent he breaks the fourth wall and
addresses the reader directly this
combined with his infamous sure you can
uppercut on Kitty Pryde and made the
story an instant hit among Deadpool
readers while a second occurrence of
Deadpool breaking the fourth wall is not
as clearly done as issue number 27 in
issue number 28 Deadpool is approached
by bullseye asking when the last time
was that they met where Deadpool
references his own comic series stating
that their last meeting took place in
issue number 16 with Joe Kelly departing
the series after issue number 33 the
writing duties were handed over to
Christopher priest with issue number 34
who stayed on until issue number 45 and
it was here that the modern-day Deadpool
was born and capitalizing on Joe Kelly's
idea of breaking the fourth wall and
combining it with his own Anthony as
being the writer who received titles
before they were cancelled the
Christopher priest made Deadpool as
Zeitung as possible as an example in the
first few pages of his inaugural title
with issue number 34
Christopher priest depicts Deadpool
traveling to his new home representing
his transition from Joe Kelly to his new
rider or he
counters all the characters previously
written by Christopher priest who were
now canceled free marking that he won't
end up in the same way and that he won't
be canceled and stuck on the back of his
shelf
Deadpool effectively escapes by diving
into a lake which starts the beginning
of the actual story in a world of young
readers whose minds were moving at an
ever-increasing rate
Christopher priest wrote Deadpool in a
way they capitalized on this readers
themselves wanted fast-paced action
combined with comedy something that
Marvel was running very short on at the
time and now as time passed and while
various writers like Gail Simone Fabien
Miss Issa Daniel Wayne and Victor
Kichler joined the ranks of Deadpool
writers the element of his antics his
breaking the fourth wall in direct
interaction with the reader remained one
of his hallmarks leading him to become
one of the comic-book industry's most
unique characters where that being said
we're gonna go and bring this video to
an end and I will catch you guys later
peace